My mother thought going to a white
school meant I would get a better
education and I would be safer.
Wrong. That's Joey Caruso, a little
thug with a big chip on his shoulder.
You know, I managed to avoid him before
I wore these shoes.
Nice shoes. Bojangles.
Bojangles. That's not what your mother
called me when I was tap dancing in her
drawers last night.
I know you think I'm crazy, but if I let
him get away with that, he'd be doing
it all year. Now, I couldn't beat him,
but I thought maybe I could outblack
him. What?
Did I stutter? You know who I am.
You step on my shoe again.
I'm going to tell you who I am.
I don't play that.
I'm from Bed-Stuy.
Boy, I'll bring half of Marcy up in
here. Oh, I will beat your butt so bad,
you're going to need crutches in your
sleep.
Hey, this might work.
No one else I'm gonna do.
What's your name?
Chris.
I'm Dr. Raymond, your new principal.
Get off my feet.
That's funny. That's not funny.
What's your name, son?
Caruso. Fix yourself up next time you
come to my school. See those shoes.
They say something.
They say I'm a student.
I want to learn.
I want more of that and less of this.
Don't bump into me again.
Even though Caruso was messing with me,
getting embarrassed made him even
madder. So you know what's coming next?
This isn't over.
Oh, he got away with calling me that
day. But later in life, he said it at a
DMX concert and almost got stomped to
death.
Hey, you really from Bed-Stuy?
Do or die? Yeah.
You ever been shot?
No. Well, at least not yet.
I'm Greg. I'm Chris.
Greg Wuliger wasn't my first choice for
a friend, but mutual ass kicking seemed
to bring people together.
Cool shoes.
Hey, you know, if that was the new
principal, who was the old one?
I didn't touch her.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Mr. Palmer was accused of doing
something that we can't tell you about
because of the network censors.
The school settled the lawsuit out of
court, and he's not allowed to teach
anymore. If he moves to your
neighborhood, you'll get a warning.
After school, I had a plan.
This is crazy.
Man. It's a school fight. School fights
only last a minute. Somebody always
comes and breaks them up. You have to
do with getting the first punch.
Somebody will stop it.
What you waiting for cornbread.
This should be over in a minute.
Wait.
Wait!
Wait for-- Thank you.
Thank you. Yep. Come on, man.
Come on. I got a schedule. Let's go,
man. Wait, wait.
Hold on. There's a kid trying to catch
you.
Yeah. Yeah. I see.
You. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh. Oh.
Bet you don't give me tomorrow.
I bet I do.
You do. I gotta go. Sit down. Cut that
out, you bunch of hoods. Back off.
I was still hungry, but I was almost
home. What could go wrong now?